foreign
I was wondering if you have an opinion
on the proposed fair tax act that would
eliminate federal taxes impose a
national sales tax on new Goods
purchased and eliminate the IRS as we
know it it's the perfect question for
the two of us I don't know two people
that hate taxes more than me and Dave
Ramsey
um well I've always been a fan of this
in fact I lived for years in Atlanta and
Neil Bortz who was a well-known local
talk radio guy you're probably friends
with Neil I know well uh he was a big
proponent of this and and wrote another
show several times back in the day
talking about yeah they're selling book
on best-selling book on this very issue
and I'm not going to endorse the book
nor am I going to endorse the policy but
I like the direction that it's heading
uh and I'll tell you why
um I I think a sales tax uh it forces
the consumer to kind of deal with it and
it's not the federal government
mandating what is taken from my income
um I like flat tax idea which is really
the the guts of what Neil Bortz was was
kind of proposing and that's everybody
pays the same tax rate there's this
cultural divide now that the media uh
and a lot of people on the left have
created this fairness doctrine that the
person who makes more should have to pay
a higher percentage and it's become this
virtuous idea and in all reality if you
look at the actual data now folks some
of you are going to get offended right
now and that's okay but here's what I
want you to do while you're getting
offended I want you to actually go on
this thing called Google and I want you
to do your own research be brave enough
to research what I'm saying because
here's what you'll find
most people in America in fact it's
right below 50 I believe Now 51 51 Dave
corrects me don't pay any federal income
tax and yet we're going after
appointment and let's go step further
yeah sure and a large number of that
group not only don't pay right they
receive that's correct the unearned
income tax credit that's right meaning
they get money back from the government
it's only it's not back from the
government because they never gave it to
him in the first place it's an
entitlement it's they are given that's
right their lives are subsidized and and
you're not you're not evil if that's you
okay we're not mad at you about that
that's the system that's in place but 51
percent of Americans pay absolutely
nothing
yeah so this idea in the federal income
tax program that that's not that's not
fair that's right so then they say not
only that's happening but now they want
to have people who are wealthy who help
create jobs by the way and help create
enough tax income for all of the
entitlements that those 51 percent get
you want to put more burden on this hook
so I love the flat tax that is kind of
the fair taxes or sales tax exactly
taxes I know but I I love the actual
flat tax on an income tax because I
think that that is truly Equitable and
everybody now is paying the same amount
and so you know the actual fair tax act
is not up for vote and I don't know wait
I don't know where you got this that
it's actually happening yeah it's not
it's not even close to happening it's a
it's a a a you know a discussion to try
to get people jacked up and it's been
going on for 20 plus years that book is
worth reading because the biggest gripe
that people have mathematically and it's
a fair argument
um it is that under a fair tax a uh an
ad valorem taxes national sales tax and
no income tax at all then you would have
to you would need to for it to be
correct I I for it to be Equitable not
fair or to be Equitable and bortz's
proposal the actual fair tax people are
proposing this you would have exemptions
on things like food yeah because if you
make thirty thousand dollars a year and
you pay Inc or you pay sales tax on
everything you buy you end up paying a
larger percentage of your income in
taxes than say I would
and that's not Equitable correct okay uh
I wouldn't want a single mom making 20
000 to have uh you know have a a higher
tax rate than I do yeah that's not right
and so you have to have some exemptions
in there on income and on types of
purchases to make the thing start to
have some more Equity to it but the
beauty of it is you consume you choose
that's correct now in the state of
Tennessee this is actually what we have
we have a moderately to high sales tax
nine and three quarter percent about ten
percent okay is our sales tax in the
state of Tennessee and uh we have zero
income tax and our economy is booming
yes yes because because people come here
like crazy that are producing things
like jobs and businesses and they come
here they're moving in here the same
thing with Texas same thing with Florida
the states that don't have an income tax
have prospered inordinately art Laffer
has written a lot about this that's
right and uh so it's a very interesting
discussion now you can get all pissed
off and lefty or righty about it one way
or the other if you want but that's you
know you probably ought to just listen
to one of those political shows to do
all that stuff that that's not political
this is math right okay it is not
Equitable not fair
for people to pay absolutely zero that's
correct whether they're rich or whether
they're poor and 51 percent of Americans
pay zero
income tax at the federal level
zero none
that's a half of you and it kind of
describes why the voting Falls where it
does
is actually if the voting falls about
that way okay on national elections and
so you know and it you're right it has
been trumped up by the that's bad bad
phrase bad phrasing yes right it's been
it's been pushed by the uh the media
because they can sell hate that's
correct and you know make the poor
people hate the rich people the rich
people hate the poor people all this
kind of stuff this class division thing
and it you know if we can create
division to keep people angry they'll
keep watching our news channel and
that's not a good plan so uh
I I mean I've spent a lot of time back
20 years ago I was on board the show
several times we discussed this it was a
very interesting discussion yeah it's
well thought out it's a good
intellectual exercise but Jonathan
here's the truth
it's not gonna happen that's that's the
other side of it okay you're not gonna
get a fair tax a national sales tax to
do away with the IRS
your your lifts to God's ears that the
IRS went away but uh but they're not
going it's there's too much going on
here I mean here's the thing you put the
income tax business out of business
I mean you're talking about H R Block
TurboTax are gone gone oh yeah just poof
well all the entitled nothing to do all
those governments do you think they're
going to be for this no no yeah yeah the
entire establishment will never allow
this to happen the people could make it
happen but outside of that that's a
whole yeah just fire everybody it's a
whole difference up there which
literally would be a great idea yeah but
um
yeah it would be but you know it's
interesting you know because when you
start looking at this you got to
understand too that you we hear
inflation in the news every day let's
talk about one of the most hot bed
issues uh hot button issues in America
right now is inflation but here's the
deal if if if if the people of America
in Mass let's say they got a hold of
what we teach here on the Ramsey Show
and they all started budgeting and they
went to the envelope system they used
those wallets and they did everything
the way we teach and they said you know
what we're going to severely cut back on
all of our excess spending okay four
walls that's it watch how prices would
come down Dave because these could the
targets
if Ramsay met the Millennials
minimalists in the middle game
minimalists yeah in the in the
marketplace yeah and all of America
adopted
for 90 days Dave I think 90. it'd be
like it'd be like putting people on
strike yeah and then
shut the freaking place down yeah you'd
get some uh Bozo's attention yeah I got
to tell you I mean Bezos attention it
would put some debt in the inflation and
because but we spend like drunken
Sailors As Americans credit cards
Sailors get a bad reputation drunken
Congressman that's a fair point they
spent a lot more that's true sorry don't
be messing with our Sailors both my
grandfathers were in the Navy I should
stipulate it isn't a great old saying
and I it it was more more
stereotypically true in the old days but
yeah there we go
oh so Jonathan sorry it's a good thing
to give us a little soapbox on here but
appreciate you asking the question not
gonna happen
um
wouldn't make any of us mad if something
like this or something move this
direction where everybody everybody
ought to put something in the you know
everybody ought to put something in the
pot you know you ought to pay your
military that's right you got to pay for
your interstates you're driving on
everybody ought to put something in this
is the Ramsay show